welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Ghostbusters after life
released a trailer for the follow-up to
Ghostbusters 1984 and Ghostbusters 2
with many of the creative team from the
originals returning including
appearances by Bill Murray dan Aykroyd
Ernie Hudson Sigourney Weaver and Annie
Potts and written directed by Jason
Reitman son of the originals director
Ivan Reitman it looks like this new film
is getting a lot of things right the mix
of comedy with true horror subtle
callbacks to the beloved nerdy
characters themselves and a no cliche
soft piano cover of the Ray Parker jr.
themed past I'd rather just not have it
hopefully they'll put the original in
the movie let's run through this trailer
to break down anything you might have
missed spoiler warning in case I
accidentally spoil the movie like a
[ __ ] here we go what are you doing
here in summer go anyway
honestly my mom won't say it but we're
completely broke any on this thing
that's left in our name
this is creepy old farmhouse my
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere okay so we meet the family the
heart of this film stranger things Finn
wolf part it's Trevor McKenna grace is
Phoebe and their mother Kali played by
Carrie [ __ ] they've moved to Summerville
Oklahoma into their grandfather's old
house now it's not confirmed yet but
it's pretty clear that their grandfather
is Egon Spengler who's played by the
late great Harold Ramos there's a lot of
clues but you can already tell by
Phoebe's classes which are almost
exactly the same kind that Spangler wore
in their home there's a framed photo on
the side table that kind of looks like
it could include Ramos and some have
also said that the photo by the doorpost
back there looks kind of like an image
of the Real Ghostbusters animated series
kind of hard to tell now I guess it's
also possible that this farmhouse
belonged to the stan's family the house
that Rey mortgage three times Steve the
money for their business never gonna
regret this ring my parents left me that
house I was born there you're not gonna
lose the house everybody has three
mortgages nowadays but it is almost
certainly Spangler's house as we will
see from the rest of the trailer why'd
you bring me up here
your tailor value
what is that Trevor makes friends with
some of the Somerville kids and they
hang out over this mineshaft now later
in the trailer we will see that the
Somerville mines are owned by Shandor
mining company established in 1927 so
this is an easter egg nodding to Ivo
Shandor from the first film leader of
the cult worshiping dozer and the
villain of the Ghostbusters videogame
stance and Spangler explained the
history of the building and Shandor the
whole building is a huge superconductive
antenna that was designed and built
expressly for the purpose of pulling in
and concentrating spiritual turbulence
the architects name was Evo Shandor I
found it in Tobin's spirit guide he was
also a doctor performed a lot of
unnecessary surgery and then in 1920 he
started a secret society after the first
world war Shandor decided that society
was too sick to survive and he wasn't
alone even close to a thousand followers
when he died and conducted rituals up on
the roof bizarre rituals intended to
bring about the end of the world and now
it looks like it may actually happen
they also explained that the building
was rigged with unusable girders all
riveted girders with chorus of pure
selenium perhaps that selenium was mined
here in Oklahoma and later in his life
Spangler moved to this location to
investigate the paranormal activity of
Sanders mines let's move on somehow
the town that isn't anywhere near a
tectonic plate that has no fall lines no
fracking no loud music even he's shaking
on a daily basis
I remember that one summer we died under
a table okay we meet mr. Gruber's in
Nepal read a seismologist studying the
town's unusual daily earthquakes he's
apparently a fan of the Ghostbusters
from their heroics in New York in the
1980s and I'm wondering if you might
actually be a Gozer worshipper who has
come to this town under the guise of
research we'll see
actor Tracy Letts cameos is a guy in a
workshop with rows of keys maybe there's
some connection here to the keymaster of
gozer the demigod vinz clortho who
possessed rick moranis is luis and
joined his counterpart Zul who inhabited
dana it'd be interesting if let's his
character gets inhabited by the
keymaster and Carrie [ __ ] gets inhabited
by the gatekeeper
since let's and [ __ ] are married in real
life but the big reference here is the
stack of books just like the one in the
library in the first movie symmetrical
book stacking just like the Philadelphia
man turbulence of 1947 you're right no
human being would stack books like this
I'm praying that after they rights in
this table someone says and the flowers
are still standing but before we get to
new thanks to manscape comm for
sponsoring this episode
manscape is the only men's brand
dedicated to below the weights grooming
and hygiene it's a holiday gifting
season and you deserve the gift of
manscaped in their perfect package
essentials kit which is the world's
first all-in-one manscaping kit that
makes manscaping safe and easy be sure
to try out the crop preserver anti
chafing ball deodorant and the grapple
Reviver refreshing spray it's right why
wouldn't you put deodorant on a
smelliest part of your body
I mean busting might make it feel good
but you also gotta bust the bad smells
from a TIA so when you purchase the
perfect package 2.0 kit online at
manscaped com
you'll get the biggest bang for your
buck as a subscriber you will get 20%
savings on your order instantly a new
replacement blade refill for your lawn
mower trimmer delivered to your door
every three months making sure your
trimmer stays fresh and clean and for a
limited time subscribers will get not
one but two free gifts the shed travel
bag performance it h8 boxer briefs
ladies this is really the perfect gift
for your Bad Santa this holiday season
and fellas when you trim the tree the
presents look bigger yeah 20% off free
shipping and to free gifts when you
purchased the new perfect package 2.0
Kate with my code new rock and manscaped
Becca
let's move on
I found this in my living room Oh killer
replica a replica of what a ghost trap
baby vines under the floorboards a ghost
trap in a trapdoor nice later grew
person will briefly open this trap and a
ghost is definitely in there notice the
three note piano cue here goes trap that
is the same exact creepy score in the
opening scene of the original film you
smell something onward there hasn't been
a ghost sighting in 30 years New York in
the eighties it's like The Walking Dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom okay there's a shot of
a creepy factory setting and a ghost
that resembles Slimer but might not be
him exactly the original actors writers
joked that Slimer was the ghost of John
Belushi
maybe this film won't continue that
tradition with a classified bull roaming
vapor affectionately based on the ghost
of Harold Ramis and maybe it's these
kids grandfather who is in the trap and
stacked all the books as he found them
in that library who person shows them
the old news footage from the original
films and Phoebe follows a PKE meter to
this basement accessed by sliding down a
pole just like the Ghostbusters
firehouse moving on my grandfather died
my mom says we're just here to pick
through the rubble of Slice
women
[Music]
who are you okay there's any doubt this
is definitely Spangler's farm not just
because the Spangler jumpsuit among
those four there are petri dishes of
spores mold and fungus that are
everywhere just says Spangler told us if
he clicks I collect spores molds and
fungus and that's just gotta be
Spengler's collection among the proton
pack they're moving on
[Music]
call it karma
then everything happens for a reason
okay over the shots of the sand or mine
that I mentioned before we hear the
voice of Venkman in the first film iswe
call it a call it la call it karma I
believe that everything happens for an
trevor finds the ecto-1 in the shed
which we see more of in the next clip
come on darling
some a ghostly force attacks maybe on a
school bus and then she faces some epic
Hellmouth where you can make out demonic
hands reaching out at her and the return
of the terror dog is confirmed with one
stepping on the hood of GRU persons car
and then Trevor joy rides the ecto-1 and
the license plate is unchanged the car
is unveiled plate first as it was in the
first movie and this is the ecto-1 and
not the upgraded ecto-1 a from
ghostbusters - that just might be a
different car entirely though maybe
Stan's will roll up in it and be awesome
moving on to the final clip is a Connor
State
okay we learned the ecto-1 has a gutter
seat
awesome which it did not have in the
original film but the toy did have a
seat on the roof and they chased down
this class v vapor through the town
frying up the buildings with the stream
as the ecto-1 classic siren blares see
it's little things that have looped the
strongest nostalgia and it wasn't in the
us trailer but the German trailer
featured them with the ecto goggles
which printed a Polaroid comment down
below with your favorite part of this
trailer follow me on Instagram and
Twitter a da boss and subscribe to new
rock sir-sir breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]